[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
Shania Twain has sold over 90 million
albums worldwide is the first and only
artist to receive CMT's artist of a
lifetime award but after going through a
public divorce from her husband and
collaborator Mutt Lange and experiencing
vocal issues from Lyme disease Shania
stepped away from the spotlight
now after 15 years Chennai is back with
a brand new album and the Grammy Award
winning singer is now opening up about
life love and her future on the stage
[Music]
talk me through the the one that the
technical part of what happened with
your with your voice and then to the
emotional part first of all my voice was
giving me so many problems over the
years my headlines disease and that
damaged some nerves in my vocal cords
and it it's been a journey that alone in
itself emotionally I was distraught I
was grieving for the longest time
believing that I would never sing again
professionally how long of a period was
that well that was from the last tour so
not long after up was released but
before Caesar's Palace I all those years
I never thought that I would ever
understand perfect were you working on
another plan at that point did you like
do you still have in your back pocket
something that you can put your
attention on if in fact it does get to
that point at heart I'm really a
songwriter I'm a songwriter above all
things yeah and I'm gonna keep
songwriting I'm not gonna quit that and
I will write for other singers who can
sing and can record
I talk to you when you had just turned
50 and you had said your goal was to
release this record while you were still
50 I know
it's two and a half years to do this and
I'm going to be 52 when they album comes
out the album comes out that's okay
that's okay you're there you also had
said that you did not start worrying
about 50 until you were 49 at the last
minute it all sort of it all sort of hit
you now that 50 has happened yeah see ya
spontaneous emotions I don't like living
too far in the future like I was over
you you know why worry about 50 when
you're 45 right so do you still have
that attitude now that 50 has come and
gone
yeah told you I'm going I'm using into
this uh yeah I have no problem with the
aging thing
are you still setting goals for
accomplishments that you want to points
maybe I should stay away from doing that
I really am more of a go-with-the-flow
kind of person yeah and I don't like
walking myself in locking myself in just
two things makes me anxious
to be strong
[Music]
what is it like to try and release a new
record while having a kid almost 16
years old at home dealing with sort of
that well my time everything around his
life schedule which every working mother
knows what that's all about
does he appreciate that as much as you
would like him to I think he does oh
really
yeah he's very supportive okay you know
I've seen them maturing up now he's he's
quite mature and he he really does
appreciate it hi dude I try to do it all
yeah well I'm quite traditional as a
parent I like sit-down dinners I like
cooking breakfast on Sunday mornings I
like you know I stopped making his lunch
and I'm doing the school runs so I'm
just I'm very involved in I love family
and I love home I've asked you this
before but everything you've been
through in your life I need to know now
have all your dreams come true no I've
got lots of dreams you do yeah yeah I
mean a lot of my dreams have come true
and a lot of things have come true that
I didn't even dream about because I
thought it was out of reach
I mean now that my son is getting older
he's gonna be gone in three years
they're gonna be crying he's gonna fly
yeah no no that's why I'm dreaming okay
yeah what am I gonna do when he's gone
yeah I'll have time to act I'll have
time maybe maybe I'd like to do me you
know I'd like to do some cooking books I
love cooking yeah I'd like to write more
books period yep I love writing yeah
that's what I really like to do I could
just do that off it's alright
I don't want to jump out of a plane
anymore I've done that twice yep those
things I won't do again